12:45 restate my assumptions 1
mathematics is the language of nature to
everything around us can be represented
and understood through numbers 3 if you
graph the numbers of any system patterns
emerge therefore there are patterns
everywhere in nature fine don't know how
to fight
or do I
like this line how about giving me a
number that when divided by the product
of its digits the quotient is 3 and if
you were to add 18 to this number the
digits would be inverted
24 that is correcting Dave listen up
please
next we are going to steal first
distract target then block is blind jab
count with cross to left cheek
discombobulated date will attempt wild
haymaker and we connect jaw now fracture
break cracked ribs you kicked a
diaphragm in summary is ringing jaw
fractured three ribs cracked four broken
diaphragm hemorrhaging that's gonna last
until next year you're gonna be in here
regurgitating Gordon wood talking about
you know the pre-revolutionary utopia
and the capital farming effects of
military mobilization as a matter of
fact I won't because would drastically
underestimates the impact would
drastically underestimates the impact of
social distinctions predicated upon
wealth especially inherited wealthy you
got that from Vickie's work in Essex
County page 98 right yeah I read that
too are you gonna play Joyce the whole
thing for us you have any thoughts of
your own on this matter Adam Smith needs
revision what are you talking about
we all go for the blonde
we block each other not a single one of
us he's going to get her so then we go
for her friends but they will all give
us the cold shoulder because nobody
likes to be second choice no fart if no
one goes to the blonde
we don't get in each other's way and we
don't insult the other girls assuming we
win needs to be something that you
senior just like man I just gotta have
it
apples
excuse me
now Apple like the fruit the fruit of
creation Apple it's simple but
sophisticated for Atari in the phone
book fish
this--that's that is so much better than
phaser beam computers listen to me see
that guy I'm gonna swing by are you just
gonna grab them you got it
I'll Electrify your arm you won't be
able to open your hand you can do this
ever
Oh easy c11 where to go this is the
answer it says here that a both of ideas
gonna strike the Clocktower precisely
10:04 p.m. next Saturday night if we
could somehow harness this light share
it into the flux capacitor so spite work
next Saturday night
we're sending you back to the future
Oh